[Music]
on this Thursday night suspended India
hits pause on handing out new visas to
Canadians it's a bit Troublesome for us
the Ontario premier's astonishing u-turn
on the Green Belt I am very very sorry
what happens now
a global news exclusive the RCMP
investigation into a Canadian man's
death in DC with the Chinese dissident
once ominously told a friend
and one couple's dearly held Treasures
now up for auction Donna didn't want
flowers for her birthday she wanted a
John Deere watering can
Rubble National with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us the
rift between India and Canada is growing
much deeper India has suspended all Visa
services for Canadians trying to travel
to that country and the Canadian
government is reducing staff levels at
its diplomatic missions in India prime
minister Justin Trudeau is not backing
down from his assertion there are
credible allegations of a potential link
between Indian government agents and the
killing of sick leader Hardeep Singh
Niger in June
I can assure you the decision to share
these allegations on the floor of the
House of Commons Monday morning was not
done lightly
it was done with or Monday afternoon was
done with the utmost seriousness
Trudeau was calling on the government of
India to help get to the truth of the
matter though India has called the
allegation absurd we have complete
coverage tonight including how this
affects Canadians trying to get a visa
to India We Begin tonight with turia
Israeli
Canadian citizens waiting for Indian
I don't know why they are creating this
maybe it will be Troublesome for us only
the agency that processes applications
has suspended services in Canada until
further notice
it's part of a spiraling diplomatic
dispute between Ottawa and Delhi over
the killing of Hardeep Singh Niger
India vehemently denies it had anything
to do with the Canadian citizens murder
and says the allegation is damaging
Canada's International reputation any
country that needs to look at this I
think it is Canada and its growing
reputation as a place as a safe haven
for terrorists for extremists and for
organized crime the Canadian government
is standing by the claim and has started
pulling diplomats out of India after
they received threats on social media we
are going to continue to do the work
necessary to keep Canadians safe and to
uphold our values my advice would be to
be very careful and deliberate in the
next steps this former foreign policy
adviser to prime minister Justin Trudeau
says there's a reason India is
retaliating with visas this was for them
an easy step that they could take as
they looked at the toolkit that they had
at their disposal to dig in even deeper
it also has the potential to put
domestic pressure on Trudeau course is a
very large engine to ask for here
um
it's growing it's a faster sector
fastest growing sector of new immigrants
in Canada prime minister Justin Trudeau
would not answer when asked whether
Canada plans to retaliate with its own
Visa suspension for Indian citizens
planning to come here
I'm foreign Aster in Toronto India's
decision to Halt visas has hit
indian-born Canadians the hardest many
now cut off from loved ones back home
shocked and suddenly shut out I have
family I have a whole family I'm the
only one here beneath tanushri bashui's
frustration is grief my husband just
passed away of kicking his asses and
India is to be his final resting place
[Applause]
you fighting the leader why public had
to suffer every year up to 80 000
Canadians travel to India on tourist
visas we've seen the interruption of
Visa processing during Wars and
conflicts and border conflicts but never
something like this and what about the
people who've already obtained Indian
visas that's not impossible but that's
definitely a possibility
hates uncertainty
uncertainty that has left so many Indian
Canadians on edge we never expected that
these things will happen so fast and
relations will come to this level were
Ginger Sani a Punjabi radio host is not
taking listener calls on the issue
concerned that it would further Stoke
divisions people are trying to divide
the community right now on religious
basis religious lines so which is really
really dangerous for our
community's Harmony the new SRI bishui
blames Prime Minister Modi for her
predicament what is doing is not this
right it's not doing right why are we
gonna suffer we are because we are not
Indian city that's true a citizenship
she gave up five decades ago to become a
Canadian a decision she doesn't regret
today
foreign Asser Global News Toronto
the U.S said today it firmly rejects the
idea this issue is driving a wedge
between Canada and the United States a
U.S national security adviser says
American officials have raised the
murder allegation with the Indian
government and will not give it a
special exemption because of America's
close relationship with India Mackenzie
gray reports
it was a reiteration of a previous
accusation I'm repeating what I said on
Monday afternoon
that there are credible allegations
that we need to take extremely seriously
as
Canadians and indeed as a world the
Prime Minister tight lent providing no
new information about India's potential
involvement in the murder of Canadian
Citizen and sick leader Hardeep Singh
Niger avoiding further escalation there
is no question that India is a country
of growing importance and a country that
we need to continue to work with we're
not looking to provoke
uh or or
cause problems the desire to work with
India has led some key allies to not
publicly condemn Delhi but today
Canada's biggest partner said it raised
the issue with the Modi government it is
a matter of concern for us it is
something we take seriously but further
Allied action may be unlikely this is
not China this is not Iran this is not
Venezuela or North Korea this is India
and so this is the best we should expect
from our friends
Canada's ambassador to the United
Nations also concerned but preached
patience facts will come out facts will
emerge it's all going to take take a bit
of time and it's important not to
overreact to that those facts allegedly
not shared with the Indian government
who believes Canada has an ulterior
motive they have made delegations they
have taken action on them to us it seems
or it appears that these allegations by
the government of Canada are primarily
politically driven just Intruder raised
the allegations with the Indian
president at the G20 but today Donna he
declined to say how Narendra Modi
respond
all right Mackenzie gray in New York
City thanks Ukrainian President Vladimir
zelanski was in Washington today meeting
President Biden and American lawmakers
many of whom are reluctant to give the
same kind of support they promised last
time he visited Brittany Rosen is in
Washington with the latest details
Brittany
Donna this was President zielinski's
second trip to Washington in nine months
but this visit proved to be a bit more
turbulent than the last time he was here
he faces a Republican party skeptical to
issue new Aid and a government on the
brink of shutdown
shoulder to shoulder with Congressional
leaders zelenski arrived on Capitol Hill
determined to sway lawmakers who appear
to be in a stalemate on spending
commitments we'd greatly appreciate that
vital assistance provided by the United
States to Ukraine to combat Russian
Terror Biden who welcomed the Ukrainian
leader to the White House Thursday wants
Congress to approve 24 billion dollars
in new military and humanitarian aid but
that money is being stifled by a handful
of House Republicans we're very
concerned about accountability
stand when we provide
other Republicans say support for
Ukraine is Paramount if you let Putin
get away with this you better get ready
to fight China and Taiwan
hours before zelenski's Washington
appearance Russia launched a barrage of
missile strikes on energy facilities in
Ukraine
since the start of the war the U.S has
committed the most funding of any
country with Aid topping 112 billion
dollars President Biden will announce a
new package of military assistance today
that includes significant air defense
capabilities to help Ukraine protect its
people no Nation can be truly secure in
the world if in fact we don't stand up
and defend the freedom of Ukraine while
additional cash is crucial to sustaining
Ukraine's counter-offensive against
Russia experts say pulling back funding
would not guarantee Russia the upper
hand on the battlefield this would all
be good news for Vladimir Putin but I'm
not so sure that he's in a position to
exploit it because of the massive
Manpower shortages that the Russian army
continues to be faced with from here
zalenski will head north where he is
expected to make stops in Ottawa and
Toronto Donna Brittany Rosen in
Washington thanks
I made a promise to you
that I wouldn't touch the green belt
I broke that promise
and for that
I'm very very sorry
I pride myself on keeping our promises
stunning u-turned from Ontario's Premier
today Doug Ford is reversing his
government's decision to remove
protected Land from the green belt
around Toronto for months he has
staunchly defended the plan to carve out
land for developers but Ford now says
there was too much room for some people
to benefit over others and for ontarians
to question his motives Colin Demello
has covered this controversy right from
the start calling what finally made
Premier Ford completely switched gears
well Donna Premier Doug Ford came here
to Niagara Falls to hold a caucus
Retreat and that's where he seems to
have realized that the Greenbelt gamble
was not going to pay off those caucus
members and cabinet members told the
premier that they've been hearing severe
blowback from right across the province
that was in part one of the reasons why
the premier decided now was the time
after a year of defending the deals now
was the time to reverse course but there
were other underlying reasons as well
the Integrity commissioner revealed
today some key details about a family
fundraiser the premier had in August of
2022 his daughter was getting married
the premier was throwing a stag in his
family backyard developers were invited
they paid 150 dollars per ticket to
attend the Stag and Doe and that money
would have gone to the premier's family
his daughter to pay for her wedding the
premier was asked about that today and
about whether that money made it into
his family's pocket
I've never taken a penny from absolutely
anyone
I've never even expensed
a hamburger or chocolate bar nothing
ever I pay out of my own pocket no one
can influence me simple as that oh and
he's now admitted this was a mistake he
said sorry is that the end of it no it's
far from over remember that the RCMP has
launched some kind of a preliminary
investigation looking into whether
developers are given Insider access
whether there was any money that changed
hands and how the process was allowed to
be in the words of the opposition
corrupted to the degree that developers
had Direct influence over lands being
removed from the Green Belt remember at
the end of all of this the lands that
were removed 15 Parcels the value Rose
according to Ontario's auditor general
by 8.3 billion dollars and that is at
the heart of this entire Scandal so for
the government this is far from over
Donna all right Colin Demello in Niagara
Falls thank you
Rupert Murdoch once said he would never
retire now at the age of 92 he seems to
have changed his mind
some personal news to share with you
this morning our boss Rupert Murdoch is
transitioning from chair of our parent
company Fox Corporation
after seven decades building a media
Empire the 92 year old billionaire will
transition to chairman emeritus his son
Lachlan Murdoch will become sole chair
and CEO though he says his father will
continue to provide valued counsel to
both companies Fox News has profoundly
influenced television news and politics
since its starred in 1996 and Murdoch
has both loved and loathed and has been
demonized as a puppet master who would
pull the strings of politicians behind
the scenes
to quit or not quit the Canada Pension
Plan coming up what Alberta's debating
and the money at stake
more competition will ease sticker shock
at the grocery checkout line
eliminating the GST will get more
housing built faster
that is finance minister Christian
Freeland talking about legislation
tabled in the House of Commons today to
address the cost of living crisis it
will eliminate the GST on new rental
developments to Spur the construction of
new housing it also aims to strengthen
the competition Bureau to address
anti-competitive Behavior by grocery
store retailers as the Alberta
Government mulls exiting the Canada
Pension Plan in favor of creating its
own the province has released a new
report detailing how much money it says
it would be entitled to if it does
Alberta is the economic engine of Canada
and our young population our
nation-leading employment rate and
higher pensionable earnings means that
we're providing an outsized contribution
to CPP
according to the independent report The
Province would be entitled to 334
billion dollars by 2027 if it leaves the
CPP that's more than half of what the
national pension pool is worth the
report estimates an Alberta Pension Plan
could cost up to 2.2 billion dollars to
set up but could save five billion
dollars a year in premiums the idea is
still in its early stages the government
says it will consult albertans and
potentially hold a referendum
still ahead the RCMP investigates
China's alleged role in the death of a
BC man
[Music]
Global News has learned the RCMP is
investigating the death of a BC man who
is targeted as part of a foreign
interference campaign by the Chinese
government 57-year-old way Hugh died two
years ago from an apparent suicide
before his death he claimed he'd been
harassed and intimidated by Chinese
government agents Jeff Semple has the
exclusive details Jeff Donna way Hugh
grew up in China and was an outspoken
critic of the Chinese government two
decades ago he moved to Canada but even
here it seems he couldn't escape the
Chinese Communist party that's the
absolute get him into trouble this
friend of Wei Hugh did not want to show
her face afraid she could be targeted
for sharing Hugh's story
he and his family lived in this gated 3
million dollar property near Chilliwack
BC Hugh said he'd been followed and
received threatening messages which
included details about his children she
says he wants ominously told her
for accidents or something or Communists
called cognitive suicide he told me
that way told me then in July 2021 you
died an apparent death by Suicide
the RCMP has now launched a national
security investigation into his death a
highly unusual move after a witness told
police Hugh had complained Chinese
government agents were harassing him
I believe he's a person who easily
committed suicide he believes what is a
place right why inside a committed
suicide back in 2015 the Chinese
government issued an Interpol red notice
for Hughes arrest demanding he returned
to China part of beijing's sweeping
Crackdown on supposed Financial
criminals living abroad called operation
Fox Hunt so sometimes these Fox Hunt
efforts are are really tied to political
considerations
this Former Intelligence analyst says
operation Fox Hunt has been used to
track down and repatriate Chinese
dissidents
U.S authorities recently convicted three
men including a former New York police
officer for trying to coerce a local
couple to return to China as part of
operation Fox Hunt in another case the
victim was allegedly offered a choice
the target had two options
returned to China promptly
or commit suicide Chinese agents have a
history of taunting Fox Hunt targets to
end their lives says Dennis Molinaro
it's a way that the PRC is in essence
exporting repression one of Hughes
former business associates fellow
Chinese Canadian Wong Ching Wei was also
targeted by Fox Hunt with an Interpol
red notice
but unlike you Wong went back to China
in 2018 and turned himself in he was
then released and has since returned to
his farm in BC asked why Chinese
authorities let him leave he declined to
comment reached by phone Hugh's Widow
denied knowing anything about her
husband being wanted by China but said
he had become isolated without any
friends or even a job the political
debate around foreign interference in
this country has largely focused on
elections but Donna dissidents say
that's just one part of a broader
problem beijing's harassment of Chinese
Canadians like way Hugh
Jeff sample thanks
they'll be dearly missed next a story
anyone with a prairie past can relate to
[Music]
foreign
it's hard to know what exactly drives
people to collect stuff odds are if you
go to a farm on the Canadian prairies
you'll almost certainly find a couple of
miniature John Deere tractors the
merchandise has been popular for decades
and one couple in Strathmore Alberta
could never seem to resist buying just
one more thing Gil Tucker has their
story
one of my favorite tractors and there
are a lot of them to choose from here
special the 175th anniversary gold
Tractor Fort Dan Specht and his
cherished John Deere collectibles
here we have some pedal tractors Dan's
wife Donna's also been snapping them up
each doll has a tractor to go with them
we have the John Deere teddies we have
truck Banks I want lots of these because
oh that looks neat in our collection and
our basement got full so now they're
selling them all off a ceiling fan for
you more than 500 items on John Deere
products a collection they've been
building for the past half century four
plates four cups on the Block in an
online auction it's very impressive you
know it's not something that you can
just walk into a store and buy a
collection like this Dan had an inn I've
worked on every one of these tractors in
my time a John Deere employee for 61
years I started in 1953 I was 13 years
old a farm boy in southern Saskatchewan
worked weekends eventually working his
way up to owning a dealership he loved
John Deere a treasure Trove of memories
oh the cookie jar no cookies all of it
dear to their hearts Donna didn't want
flowers for her birthday she wanted a
John Deere watering can hoping it'll add
up to more than 50 thousand dollars in
sales kids they can wear them saying
goodbye to Decades of family fun remote
tractor
Donna bought it for me for Christmas
I had trouble operating it but the
grandkids seem to be able to operate it
very well Gil Tucker Global News
that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is St John's Newfoundland
and Labrador we'd love to see your
Canada please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you